comment vous allez bien j'espère dit le
mort dans un commentaire aux normes a
demandé de vous parler de leur nouveau
smartphone d'entrée de gamme le au nord
9a
je vous ai fait un livestream j'étais en
direct quelques jours sur youtube pour
vous présenter justement ce genre de
femme lors de la keynote dans la
présentation c'est pas si vous avez été
présente d'ailleurs si vous l'avez été
dites moi ce que vous en avez pensé en
bas en commentaire on va donc
aujourd'hui se faire un nom boxing on va
regarder à quoi ressemble aux
smartphones voir s'il intéressant et si
il peut être fait pour vous mais en
toute chose si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
je vous invite à venir vous abonner
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement on teste
des smartphones je vous présente
beaucoup de produits je parle de votre
vie numérique vous donne des conseils
pour mieux utiliser votre smartphone et
cetera et cetera et cetera on parle de
smartphones on parle de tablettes
ordinateurs de votre vie numérique
une façon un peu globale et générale si
ce n'est pas déjà fait vous invite à
vous abonner vous avez le bouton en
dessous vous cliquez comme ça vous
saurez tout la boîte est somme toute
assez classique fait voir ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur on tombe déjà sur le
smartphone qui dans sa petite protection
il ya déjà tous les autocollants de base
qu'on va pouvoir enlever et ici vous
avez un gros not for sale ici c'est
écrit en noir sur blanc comme le port
salut c'est un produit c'est pour la
presse c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez notre force et qu'est ce qu'on
a à l'intérieur de la boîte avant
continuer là-dessus
ici la caisse qu'on a de quoi ouvrir
votre tiroir de cartes sim de quoi venir
le recharger tout en sachant que ici
vous avez de l'argent micro usb
vous n'avez pas d'usb cema le bloc de
charge
je crois qu'on a fait le tour de ce que
j'ai moi dans ma boîte qui si on à magic
uoya leur magic usage facile vous
connaissez c'est l'interface de honor
c'est magic eu avec 3.1 d'aller sur
l'android dispense les contrats on est
d'accord la vie privée tout ça tout ça
oh ouais il dit le huawei a dit vous le
faut parce qu'ici vous n'avez pas de
pelé store de google
ici vous avez la galerie de howell vont
vous connaissez l'histoire
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller voir
la vidéo sur la galerie comme ça vous
saurez tout paris des marots qu'est ce
qu'on peut monter la luminosité
on peut pousser la luminosité soit sa
race est assez lumineux quand même ce
qu'il faut venir savoir ici c'est que
vous avez un écran de 6 points 3 pouces
ici c'est un écran tft c'est du lcd vous
avez une résolution de 1600 par 720
pixels à 278 pixels par pouce
ici vous n'avez pas de full hd qu'il
faut pas oublier un truc c'est qu'on est
sur un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
c'est un produit qui coûte 149 euros
1,90 il ya des choix qui ont été faits
d'un point de vue
matériel par aux normes on n'a pas tous
là dessus on peut pas tout avoir non
plus donc il faut vraiment garder sans
mémoire
149 euros 90 on prend le prix on se met
dans un coin de la tête comme ça ça nous
permet un petit peu de rationaliser tout
ce qu'on va voir ici ceci étant dit
c'est pas mal comme ça alors dites moi
ce que vous en pensez au niveau de
l'écran comment vous le trouvez moi je
trouve ça assez efficace alors on va
voir des grandes bordure ça c'est normal
à 149,90 bordure imposante sur le côté
en dessous c'est normal aussi en raw ou
pas pu se repositionne par rapport à son
prix vous avez eu l'encoche sur le au
bon ça fonctionne ok ça marche
il existe plusieurs couleurs vous avez
une couleur fantôme blue et moi j'ai la
menace blacks à leurs amis avec black
elle est sympa mais elle prend bien
toutes les traces de doigts maintenant
vous devriez voir caméra qui est situé
juste au dessus
voilà vous l'avez en plein reflet bon
une fois qu'on a oublié sa capteur
d'empreintes digitales
je pose mon doigt dépendantes en digital
saliver rouille extrêmement rapidement
vous avez un triple module photo ici
vous avez une âme et un précédent de 13
mégapixels tout bref 1.8 nous avons
c'est un ultra grand-angle de 5
mégapixels touvre iphone 2.2 avec un
champ de vision de 120 degrés et vous
avez une caméra de 2 mégapixels tout
bref 2.4 qui elle est là pour le mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués la bande
et une caméra de celle fille de 8
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.0 envoyé une
config assez classique vous n'allez pas
venir énormément vous mais vous allez
jusqu'à 12 x 4 mais bon je pense que ça
globalement pas grand-chose l'interface
est assez simple ok ça marche
après on nous annonce qu'on a vraiment
un haut parleur qui est extrêmement
puissants alors on est sur un smartphone
on aura un haut parleur mono mais on
nous dit qu'ils entrent au parlement ne
va être puissant je fais 80 8 décibels
fait voir on va pousser sa faune donc ça
c'est pas mal pas mal ici 3
ça gueule ça gueule ya vraiment du son
qui au parloir de l'autre côté c'est pas
mal hein effectivement on écoute un peu
déséquilibré parce qu'on n'a pas de haut
parleurs stéréo bon ça une fois de plus
149 euros 90 ça me paraît normal il ya
du fond la france du saut trop de points
qui est cool c'est que vous avez tac
juste la garder ses planques et là je
pas si vous le voyez bien on a une prise
jack comme ça pouvait venir brancher
votre casque vous écouterez là vous
aurez beaucoup de
après stéréo et pour voir qu'on n'est
pas sur du full hd je trouve ça pas
déconner c'est bien maîtrisée bien
calibré de la part de honor une fois de
plus on va pas tout avoir on va pas
avoir un truc de dingue mais 149,90 ça
fonctionne affichage de luminosité fait
voir qu'est ce que ça nous raconte ici
c'est peut-être un peu bleus je le mets
un peu sur chaud mais là c'est trop
l'attendait je viens cas c'est un peu
comme ça là c'est là qu'on aura le
meilleur rendu on a un mode confort dg
aussi qui est certifié donc je peux
venir attendait l'activer ou a eu un peu
mal aux yeux
oh la vache alors c'est peut-être bien
pour le confort des yeux mais moi je
trouve ça vraiment pas très très beau
non ce que je vous conseille de faire
c'est vous venez électivement dans votre
température de couleur unie casse un peu
l'effet bleuté ça sera beaucoup mieux
maudit book mode sombre ouais bon alors
ici on n'est pas sur un écran oled donc
le mode son ca va pas venir vous
économiser de la batterie côté
performances et si on a un processeur
médiathèque c'est emt 6762 r vous avez 3
giga de ram 64 gigaoctets de stockage
vous pouvez monter avec une carte
microsd jusqu'à 512 giga voyez si vous
mettez double carte sim plus une carte
microsd de 512 donc si vous avez besoin
de carte sim parce que vous êtes
frontaliers ou pour votre boulot et
compagnie ça c'est cool mais ça vous
empêche pas en plus de venir augmenter
la capacité de stockage de votre
smartphone mais le gros focus qui a été
fait par renault là dessus c'est
seulement du smartphone c-power your
life on parle d'une grosse batterie on
parle d'une grosse autonomie et c'est un
peu ce qu'on est recherché sur un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme
ici vous avez une grosse batterie de
5000 milliampères heures au nord nous
annonce une autonomie allant jusqu'à
trois jours alors si vous aller jusqu'à
trois jours ça va être au détriment de
pas mal de choses parce que vous avez un
mode c'est le mode de gestion
d'alimentation ultra donc c'est un mode
ultra d'économie d'énergie donc si vous
venez l'activé regardez vous avez 100
17h30 d'autonomie seules certaines
applications sont activés c'est
extrêmement minimaliste vous avez le
téléphone contacts
vous pouvez ajouter trois applications
et là vous avez une batterie qui a duré
extrêmement longtemps on veut pas sur
iphone avec quelques applications juste
six applications à venir salir
strictement aucun sens mais lorsque vous
arrivez à
5 % vous venez l'activer et vous allez
pouvoir passer des coups de fil vous
allez pouvoir joindre des amis et ça
vous regarde que les fonctions
essentielles de votre smartphone
ça c'est vraiment cool alors après le
point à point négatif c'est que vous
n'avez que la recharge ici en micro usb
vous n'avez pas du sbc vous n'avez pas
de recharge rapide il faudra vous armer
de patience et une batterie de cinq
mille vies antérieures
ça met du temps à se recharger donc
prévoyons vraiment devenir le recharger
le soir ne vous dites pas que vous allez
thakur batterie vous allez le brochet
repartir extrêmement rapidement c'est
pas vrai du coup il faudra passer par ce
mode ultra d'économie d'énergie qui lui
par contre j'aimerais vraiment vous
sauver la vie
l'idée est plutôt bonne mais évitez de
laisser votre smartphone deux cents en
dessous des 30% pour éviter les
déconvenues
le point qui est important et je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est la galerie
un plat on s'active tous vous allez
retrouver de nombreuses applications
snap sa petite-fille 10h10 express
amazonie bon j'ai pas vous faire le topo
je vous invite à voir la vidéo de la
bière ici vous savez pas comment ils
fonctionnent comme ça vous saurez tout
maintenant s'il faut savoir aussi c'est
que vous n'avez pas les sens du mot
google vous n'aurez pas les services
google
il faut le savoir donc la question qui
se pose c'est est-ce que vous utilisez
beaucoup et services google auquel cas
ce smartphone n'est pas laissé sa santé
pour vous par contre si vous voulez une
alternative à google avec la galerie
vous avez de quoi faire sur android
c'est assez intéressant
ici vous avez aussi du nfc du bluetooth
4.2 ou un produit que je trouve comme ça
assez honnête
voilà donc pour cette découverte du au
nord 9 à à vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
des jeux le messie par le nouveau
smartphone de honor tel qu'il est là
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse vous amis
des liens en bas dans la description a
vous de me dire vous maintenant ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que le fait de ne pas avoir de
prise usb c'est ces bleus quand pour
vous qu'est ce que vous pensez cette
grosse batterie de 5 millions terreur
avec ce mode ultra économies d'énergie
qui vous permettra d'aller très loin en
cas de coup dur lorsque vous avez plus
de batterie c'est pas mal c'est bien
maîtrisée quand même hein c'est bien
calibré pour voir qu'on est pas sur du
full hd bien lorsque vous le regardez
comme ça c'est pas déconner voilà pas
mal vous nous dire ce que vous en pensez
vous en bas en commentaire quant à me
retrouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer par l'état qui croyez moi on a
plein de choses à se dire
à très bientôt sur moi pour beaucoup
d'amour à trith tél 15
[Musique]
m